ALRIGHT ALRIGHT ALRIGHT
Est-ce que c'est pas l'heure d'une petite compilation de jeu ?
ALRIGHT ALRIGHT
je ne sais plus quoi faire comme intro c'est terrible
on va peut-être revenir au "yo tout le monde c'est Squeezie"
Ok le premier jeu s'appelle "Helping Hand" c'est un jeu dans lequel on vient de vivre un terrible accident et on ne peut plus que bouger la main.
Voilà on peut plus parler, plus rien faire d'autre que bouger une seule main.
Et on va devoir communiquer avec un mec qui va venir parler dans notre chambre et faudra lui répondre.
Et du coup regarder la touche 1 c'est le petit doigt, la touche 2 c'est le doigt là etc...
Pire explication du monde bien sûr comme d'hab'.
PLAY !!
"Oh cool t'es réveillé, on s'inquiétait pour toi"
Dis-moi tout
"Tu as eu un accident mais ça va maintenant"
Ok
"C'est dur pour toi d'entendre et presque tout ton corps est cassé"
Bah... C'est chiant
"Comment tu te sens ?"
J'suis en bad mec
Ce jeu est chiant, voilà je l'annule
EH c'est la première fois mon gars que je m'en bat les c*uilles comme ça d'un jeu quoi !
Eh ça m'a saouler. J'vais pas faire semblant de kiffer etc... ça m'a saoulé.
On passe à ça, à "Catch your chance" voilà c'est un petit jeu où le but c'est de choper sa copine comme ça au cinéma pour lui montrer que tu l'aime et que tu veux finalement t'introduire en elle.
Voilà prince charmant non hein, moi j'suis pas prince charmant
FIRST DATE !
3,2  j'sais pas ce qui faut faire mec, y'a pas un tuto, un truc ,non ?
C'est l'inverse de l'autre jeu, ça commence direct.
D'accord ça c'est mon bras. Et je le contrôle avec quoi ?
Ah d'accord comme ça, ok.
Et je vais m'introduire derrière elle c'est ça ?
C'est vrai que les premiers rapports t'sais comme 'fin les premier...
Pourquoi je pars... Ah merde !
Ah les contrôles c'est un peu aléatoire ok.
C'est vrai que les premières fois où t'sais tu veux tenir la main d'une copine ou quoi t'es un peu en mode grosse gêne genre faut pas qu'elle te voit avant que tu atteignes sa main.
AH VITE 180 degrés !
On prend une gifle direct là mon gars !
Ah putain mais c'est dur mec faut calculer c'est des maths hein.
Allez on y va... en mode sneaky
Elle n'a rien vu, elle est concentrée dans le film, elle bave sur les abdos de Brad Pitt.
C'est bon là, c'est bon là, OUI !
Bravo monsieur grenouille !!
Regarde elle rougit, elle est contente.
Alors que si elle t'avais pris la main dans le sac avant que t'atteigne son épaule, la gifle elle t'aurait peut-être mise.
Toujours faire attention hein, la sneaky technique.
"Scratch that itch"
Allez on y va, on va y arriver ! Oh ça accélère, Oh ça accélère, c'est la même scène mais ça va beaucoup plus vite, c'est ça ?
EH HOP !!!!
Pourquoi "you lose" , ah elle a levé la jambe et fallait passer en dessous... Quoi ?!
Attends y'a de l'arnaque là y'a de l'arnaque dans le fourneau si je puis me permettre.
On va inventer que des expressions de merde.
Faut passer sous sa jambe je pense, c'est ça ?
Mais WHAT THE FUCK mec ! Ca n'a aucun putain de sens
Mais je dois aller où ?!!
Ok c'est reparti bon mec je vais faire un grand tour avec son bras je m'en bat les steaks hein.
Ok on y va, faut que je passe en dessous ?! OH OUI OOOOOHHHHH DAAAAAMN !
Et là faut que j'aille gratter ma nuque.
WHOU regarde le visage de la déception de cette femme qui pensait que j'allais lui prendre le bras comme ça et lui demander de sortir avec moi.
Eh bah nan, j'voulais juste me gratter les veuches !
Ok "impress mom", faut impressionner maman ah c'est drôle ça !
Où est maman, elle est au milieu ? OU...OUI !! HAHA. Ah c'est la mère de la meuf.
WHAT THE FUCK mec c'est quoi cet afro avec des oiseaux dedans, d'accord. On dirai Marge Simpson, pour de vrai.
AH, oh putain, la meuf elle héberge des piafs dans sa putain de perruque c'est illégal.
J'esquive, j'veux juste l'étoile, j'esquive j'reviens OOOHHH j'ai eu l'étoile, j'impressionne maman.
Eh, on va rien dire, on va rien dire, j'aurais du perdre 100 fois mais c'est pas grave.
Putain mais ta mère, c'est quoi le délire avec ta mère là. OUIII j'ai chopé l'étoile au passage et attention j'atteins la douce épaule de sa fille sans même qu'elle sans rende compte !!
Alors si votre mère veut se mettre entre vous et votre copine ou votre copain appelez Malaise TV tout de suite !
Ca va Timothée ? Allez, profitons du film ma fille, amusons-nous. Sois pas deg fdp.
"Tongue tied" Ouh "tongue" ça veut dire langue, NAN... NAN !
OH NAN !
Pourquoi on joue à ça ?
Pourquoi est-ce qu'on joue à ça ? Expliquez-moi. Quel est le but de notre vie ?
Eh BIM dans l'œil, j'te crève l'œil batarde !
Ok try again
Bon ok je le fais sérieux. Ca c'est quand tu viens de fermer les yeux comme ça et que tu tends ta langue, pour la première fois de ta vie. C'est pas la moment le plus stressant du monde mon gars ?
OH je fais un looping, j'ai même pas fais exprès mon gars !
Le baiser n'en sera que meilleur.
Oh lala mec j'ai fais le baiser !
Bah c'est ça qu'on veut putain, c'est des jeux comme ça là !
Il est très cool ce petit jeux,  mignon comme ça.
Bon j'en ai un deuxième, 'fin à la base c'était un troisième mais du coup ça devient un deuxième.
Les amis on a une mission !! faut que je sois un peut moins proche de la caméra.
Dans ce jeux nous allons aider un mec bourré qui a des pistolets à tirer dans des bouteilles sans que le ricochet de la balle lui revienne dessus hein.
Finalement on va aider une personne qui a besoin d'assistance hein. D'ailleurs on dirait euh Amixem hein, dédicace !
*RIRE*
Donc le but c'est de péter les bouteilles bleues
Sans voilà ... que la balle nous revienne dessus
Mais ça je viens de le dire hein donc on s'en bat les couilles
Et comment je peux recomencer très très vite sans attendre 10 ans
Oh merde la fausse manip de merde ... :(
Ah ... Je vais vraiment attendre autant de temps entre chaque mort
Pour de vrai
Attends mais je suis le pire mec là !
Ahahah
Ca n'a aucun sens ce move
Ah j'adore les Challenges
Sauf le "what's in my phone" challenge
Mais c'est parti
Ok j'en ai eu une
La deuxième
Oh nul ... Mais quel move de merde !
Oh en plus j'ai mon bouton qui me fait mal ;(
J'en ai marre de ce bouton c'est un truc de malade
Allez ... Oui Oh la chance
En fait il vise mais il est bourré son bras il tremble de ouf je peux pas trop viser en fait
PAK
OHHHH Putain je vise bien là !
Je me concentre
Ah oui mais là je peux pas parce qu'il y a du ...
Faudrais que je l'envoie du coup ICI !
Pour que ça rebondisse ?
NAN
Ici
OH PUTAIN MAIS D'OU ?!
Ohhh
NAAAAAN ! :(
RIRE
Comment je fais pour avoir celle qui est en bas là mec
Ohh putain ...
C'est impossible c'est impossible Mais c'est impossible
Je vais y arriver je m'en bas les couilles
CLAP
BAHHH
Je vais y arriver je m'en bas les reins je vais y arriver mon gars je ne vis plus que pour ça
BRUIT DE RICOCHET
MAIS WHAT MAIS WHAT MAIS QUOI !
La bouteille était au milieu la balle dansait autour d'elle et ça l'a pas eu mec
OHHHHHHH
J'allais chialer
Je m'en bas les steaks c'est hyper simple
Celui la on va y arriver facilement
Celui là on va y arriver facilement
Je trouve
Je vois pas où c'est compliqué
HOP
Y'a un peu de yolo y'a un peu de yolo
On va y arriver X3
We can do it X3
Merde ...
C'est fait exprès vous en faite pas
HOP
NUL NUL
Mais pourquoi il met des planches de bois devant les bouteilles putain
Mec quand t'es bourré et que tu veux tirer avec une arme à feu sur les bouteilles tu les caches pas quoi
A moins d'être sacrément con
Putain mais c'est dur
Et cette musique là
tinlinninlin
Ah ça m'énerve
Ok mec Clint Eastwood
J'ai entendu dire que des gamins avaient besoin de mon aide par ici
SOUFFLEMENT
PAK
BOHOHOH, c'est le chapeau messieurs dames. Allez mettez des pièces dedans faites pas chier !
Et bah voilà les amis, Clint Eastwood met fin à cette vidéo j'espère quelle vous a plu si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à tirer sur le pouce bleu *PEW* comme ça.
Eh bah c'était bien sympa, y'avait du jeu très sympathique aujourd'hui hein hormis le premier qu'on a fail !
Merci d'avoir regardé on se retrouve très vite dans une prochaine vidéo, portez-vous bien TCHAO tout le monde... La Pipas !